[Musique]
lui rue de londres juste derrière moi
c'est l'adresse de google france
[Musique]
on vient de terminer la course de
présentation qu'on a regardé en fait
directement sur un écran la google
agneaux qui était faite en californie
aux us là on est en france on est si
google paris radio et dans la cour on
peut se faire un petit 360° saas et de
ses pratiques et ses les joies du métier
on s'amuse bien donc des nouveautés
super intéressant des annonces on voit
que l'effectif on google fait du google
cesserait ont sans doute ragon pas faire
ou tout ce que vous êtes mais c'est
super intéressant parce qu elles
provoquent plus loin comme de données
personnelles on va cumuler dans son
affaire d'image beaucoup le fallait ils
veulent centralisée connexion sur
différents sites s'identifie avec google
et avec ils vont venir enregistrer vos
mots de passe pour plein d'autres sites
donc ce qui fait qu en fait l'idée de
google c'est de supprimer le mot de
passe ci ont de plus de mots de passe
vous avez juste un mot de passe à
connaître c'est celui de votre compte
google et pour le reste vous valley de
riez vos connexions directement votre
smartphone vous voulez vous collectez la
wii n'ont pas cours en classe je viens
de sécurité et puis ils vont enregistrer
votre boîte bas sur cinq mâts par
exemple pour amazon pas que voulez vous
connecter sur amazon vous quittez se
connecter on n'est pas notre people
exhaustive aux caméras de son palais
avec un autre si je sais pas lambda vous
voulez vous connecter claque vous
connecter directement avec votre compte
google ça sécurise c'est bien ils ont
juste vos mots de passe pour déjà le
faire au de compte ça c'est aussi va
changer bref c'est une solution
tout-en-un centralisée directement chez
google donc à de sécurité il ya le côté
inclusion il ya plein de choses
intéressantes donc on va reparler
aujourd'hui et vous allez voir c'est un
sujet passionnant ça va constantin on
est très bien et toi ont très bien ouais
on est bien il fait beau il fait chaud
c'est presque l'été on en tee-shirt à
22h donc c'est plutôt agréable andres
est super cool alors vient de se
terminer la google ayo qui a été
retransmis ce qui se passait aux us mais
nous on l'a regardé ici depuis google
france et merci pour l'invitation
alors on va parler de plusieurs sujets
ce qu'on commence par parler matériel
parce qu'on voit que vous rentrez je
dire les deux pieds dedans haut niveau
au niveau matériel google jusqu'à
présent c'était alors il ya plein de
choses il ya l'eastern est un axe il ya
les google home avant google neige voilà
il ya toute cette partie maison
intelligente connectés mais en dehors de
la maison connectée alors effectivement
les sonnettes et compagnie mais au delà
de la maison vous étiez déjà sorti de la
maison avec les pixels burse à avancer
avec les pixels six pixels 6 procure
sorti l'année dernière là il ya un
nouveau pixels mais on vend pas des
instants mais là vous allez voir plus
loin on avait des bugs dans la mode pro
qui vont arriver il n'y avait pas de
mondialisme y arrive et vous est même
allé jusqu'à dire regardez là on en 2022
c'est bien mais en 2023 reste qu'on va
sortir à sortir une tablette ont attisé
un petit peu en effet alors oui en effet
google est connue initialement comme un
moteur de recherche et puis ensuite on
est passé sur plein d'autres produits
google maps youtube etc et en effet
depuis quelques années on se on est de
plus en plus sérieux sur le hardware
donc en effet on a commencé
progressivement avec les outils plutôt
l'est pour tout ce qui te concerne la
maison et puis pixels est arrivé là la
toute dernière version était en effet le
pixel 6 qui a intégré une puce dédiée
pour l'intelligence artificielle et une
autre puce aussi dédié fait maison
d'ailleurs pour la sécurité c'est la
nouvelle tensor pour exactement votre
puce au processeur qui fait tourner et
c'est la puce titan elle tandem deux
exactement dans l'affairé de sécuriser
en fait le smartphone et toutes les
données qui sont sur les smartphones les
données critiques et en fait là on a
annoncé dans le cas de google ayo donc
la gamme à des pixels 6 donc c'est les
pixels 6 ha qui seront en prévente le 21
juillet en france est disponible à la
vente le 28 juillet alors pour vous
situer la gamme à la gamme assez on va
dire la gamme light parce que ça serait
un peu le dégrader mais c'est la gamme
un peu moins cher en fait un peu moins
cher un peu plus accessible en effet
mémoire mission non plus c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire que c'est une
version qui est un peu moins compliqué
pour reprendre ton terme en effet c'est
à dire que là par exemple le pit celle
ci ça intègre un appareil photo qui est
un peu moins de pixels que le pixel
syspro donc il a 12 millions de pixels
mais néanmoins on a quand même fait le
choix est ce un choix important de ne
pas faire de compromis sur la puce donc
tensor est tight un m2 qui sont intégrés
en effet dans le pixel 6 ha est en effet
on développe cette gamme pixels de plus
en plus donc on a annoncé les pixels
vote pro qui vont arriver en même temps
en fait que les pics et s'installer puis
7 buts trois en deux mots on avait une
première gamme qui étaient les pixels
bugs et donc maintenant on passe sur la
gamme pro qui a tout un système en fait
une puce dédiée encore une fois basée
sur l'intelligence artificielle pour
pouvoir gérer la qualité du son et
surtout gérer les bruits ambiants donc à
une réduction de bruit active
intégré et c'est une première pour nous
en effet et on travaille aussi pour
rendre aussi un son spatialisé qui va
arriver dans un temps 2 sur ces big des
pixels bugs pro il fait alors de 119
pour la france est donc en effet on
développe cette gamme et donc on a eu
certaines surprises côté google on a
présenté en effet une pixels watch qui
va arriver aussi du coup au printemps et
on a aussi et c'est une première en
effet montré
une tablette sur laquelle on travaille
alors cette tablette là elle est issue
d'un travail aussi qui est basée sur ce
que android fait aussi côté google donc
on a des équipes dédiées chez android
qui travaillent sur comment rendre
android accessible compatibles et
surtout utile en fait sur différents
types d'usagés donc ça peut être les
smartphones les smart roach mais
évidemment aussi des tablettes est donc
là on a sorti une version android pour
les tablettes très efficace et on va
l'intégrer in fine est évidemment dans
cette tablette qui arrivera un moment en
2023 mais c'est quoi la limite parce
qu'en fait vous google au niveau
software vous savez tout faire de tout
ce qu'on sait faire aujourd'hui de dire
voilà après il ya des choses qu'on sait
pas encore faire mais vous serez les
faire demain vous êtes google donc au
monde il ya un autre a raconté mathieu
au niveau hardware moi je me rappelle
quand je parlais il ya quelques années
avec des journalistes n'étaient pas en
fait google ils sortent les pixels mais
il cherche pas à les vendre ils veulent
montrer les techno ils veulent montrer
ce qu'ils savent faire on va toujours
dit c'est plus du tout la même chose ah
non c'est clair pour conquérir un marché
alors on est là parce que on pense qu'on
a une carte à jouer déjà en fait on a en
effet comme tu le disais tout à l'heure
où google est connu surtout pour le
software donc le moteur de recherche
l'intelligence artificielle et on est
persuadé qu'en fait toute cette
connaissance qu'on a acquise au fur et à
mesure des années et même des décennies
parce qu on a vingt ans maintenant on
est capable aujourd'hui
on est capable de les intégrer en effet
dans ces nouveaux appareils et c'est
tout l'intérêt pour nous c'est de nous
dire comment est ce qu'on peut aborder
le hardware de façon un peu différente
et qu'est ce qu'on peut y apporter donc
cette fameuse puce par exemple tensor
permet de débloquer énormément de choses
donc là actuellement on est capable par
exemple de faire de la retranscription
orale même si on n'est pas connecté on
peut faire de la traduction automatique
même si on n'est pas connectée
directement dans le smart directement
dans le smartphone en device donc si tu
vas demain au portugal tu vas pouvoir
activer son réseau sans réseau peut
parler à tout le monde et parler avec
tout le monde et tu te faire comprendre
aussi ce qui
était d'ailleurs tu vois cette
technologie là est intégré aussi dans
les pixels de ce procès à dire que tu
vas pouvoir a parlé dans une langue avec
les pixels de ce protocole alors non là
il faudra une connexion parce qu'il est
connecté en effet à ton smartphone il a
besoin d'être connecté mais par contre
tu pourra entendre ce que te dis ton
interlocuteur dans une langue étrangère
directement dans typique c'est le buzz
pro oui mais sans réseau juste pour
smartphones et mais j'écoute à ma
connaissance il faut quand même un
réseau et donc cette gamme là en effet à
duerne on pense qu'on a une carte à
jouer et on reçoit aussi un un retour
très optimiste en fait des marchés là ce
qu'on a annoncé ce soir c'est que le
pixel 6 par exemple s'est vendu si on
additionne les ventes de pixels 4 et 5
exactement avec les pixels 6 on en vend
beaucoup plus encore donc donc s'il ya
aussi un engouement fait de la pub je
dirais oui l'excellent avance à sept
écosse aujourd'hui vous êtes mis sur le
marché grand public totalement à grands
coups de spots d'affichage enfin voilà
on sait que vous êtes là et aujourd'hui
on veut pas louper en fait c'est vrai
qu'on est allé très progressivement en
fait comme c'est un nouveau marché on y
aller de façon graduelle est en effet
maintenant on est de plus en plus
présent et on essaie toujours de
communiquer avec une façon un peu décalé
on est google après tout mais on rentre
aussi dans les codes des marchés
évidemment pourquoi est ce que j'irai
prendre une monde google versus une
autre monde mais mise à part aux us
c'est quoi le truc qui fait que je me
dis allez cette montre là elle fait
prendre alors ouais os
de toute façon est accessible pour
toutes les montres donc en fait
concrètement on va avoir une expérience
qui va être similaire maintenance et
l'intégration en effet dans tout
l'écosystème google qui va est
probablement beaucoup plus poussée alors
sur la montre on est encore là on vient
tout juste de l'annoncer donc on va
commencer à donner un peu plus de
détails dans les prochaines semaines
prochains mois jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit
accessible mais en tout cas il y aura
une expérience un peu plus poussée en
effet avec les pixels et c'est vraiment
l'objectif aussi pour nous c'est de
continuer à proposer des choses très
innovante sur ses amarres et là on
regardera ça j'ai compris il ya toute
cette eau sur l'écosystème qui est
importante et qui se développe de plus
en plus au niveau du hardware alors j'ai
vu des choses vachement intéressante
aussi au niveau software notamment au
niveau d'une est max moi j'utilise
beaucoup de l'eastern max dans ses
machines et et en fait on voit
qu'aujourd'hui on n'aura plus besoin de
dire attention chez vous auquel google
donc en fait j'ai vu deux choses
première chose que tu regardes ton est
au max et il faut que tu le regardes du
coup c'est comme si tu communiquer avec
lui et tu lui dis fais ci fais ça tu
poses des questions et ça marche très
bien que deuxième plan qui intéresseront
sans le regarder il va reconnaître des
combinaisons assez court allume la
lumière du salon allume la télé si et ça
et du coup ça permet de se passer de ce
mot clé ok vous exactement en fait
l'idée pour nous et c'est tout le
concept de ce qu'on appelle l'ambiante
computing donc là l'informatique
ambiante si on traduire littéralement en
français c'est de se dire on veut
s'affranchir d'une certaine manière de
tous les freins en fait des appareils
qu'on pourrait avoir donc l'idée c'est
de mettre que les appareils à
disponibilité de la voie des mouvements
parfois est en fait de pas avoir à
s'adapter aux appareils mais plutôt les
appareils s'adapte à nous et donc par
exemple sur le nez ce tome en effet ce
qu'on a développés c'est la capacité
pour la caméra qui est sur le nez stop
de détecter quand il ya un ait contact
c'est vous dire ça comme ça regarde dans
les yeux exactement et du coup il va
comprendre que tu es en train de
d'interagir avec lui et que tu as une
question à lui poser est donc le hockey
google devient du coup accessoires et en
effet on a ensuite une certaine quantité
de phrase donnée ou tu pourra interagir
directement l'idée encore une fois c'est
de pas avoir et ça arrive souvent et
attention encore une fois chez vous à
dire tout le temps auquel google ça
permet en effet de rendre l'expérience
beaucoup plus fluide il ya un autre
élément si moi j'ai trouvé très
intéressant dans google io sait aussi
comment on interagit en fait avec ces
outils là et donc on a développé dans
les ja qui sont intégrés sur sur le nez
ste maxime et tous les outils qui
intègre assistant on a développé en fait
la capacité à l'assistant de mieux
comprendre notre diction donc quand on
parle parfois on va chercher ses mots
parfois on va faire
et ne pas les trouver forcément est en
fait l'assistant va s'adapter donc quand
il va entendre justement 1
il va vous dire oui dites moi qu'est ce
que vous vouliez dire et donc il va nous
encourager à essayer de trouver cette
réponse là et donc l'interaction vient
aussi beaucoup plus naturelle de la
chine et c est ce que l'idée alors qu'on
se projette un peu comme dans le film
heures tu dis est ce que l'idée n'est
pas d'avoir une communication assez
spontané naturel et intelligentes autour
des guillemets parce qu'on n'y est pas
encore mais plus satisfaisant avec des
machines pour que ce soit comme parler
avec quelqu'un alors c'est pas ce sera
la victoire
c'est l'idée en fait tu vois wes l'idée
en fait et plutôt de pouvoir y avoir
accès quand on en a besoin pas de façon
continue parce que peut y avoir aussi
des interactions qui peuvent être adapté
ou pas au bon moment en tout cas donc
avoir une certaine spontanéité mais
garder quand même le contrôle en effet
sur cette interaction on regardera les
smartphones le testera les montres les
buzz parce que c'est intéressant de voir
quelle manière google.ch parce que c'est
quand même différent au niveau si on se
prend par exemple un google pixels ci
soit un pixel six pros on voit qu'avec
votre puce la google tensor vous n'allez
pas chercher la même chose sans pouvoir
retrouver avec une puce qualcomm où on
va aller chercher des benchmarks et
autant chez beaucoup de performances
pour le gaming vous dites ok non c'est
pas ça qui nous intéresse nous ce qui
nous intéresse c'est l'expérience google
donc on va parler benchmark les plus
haut c'est pas de la performance brute
mais par contre c'est tres tres marque
des très belles intégré c'est
intéressant ça c'est l'idée de rendre la
chose plus intelligente et plus utiles
alors ya d'autres sujets qui ont été
imposées qui sont intéressants notamment
à j'ai pris des planètes ici sur le
multi search ça c'est un truc
intéressant un exemple qui a été posée
tu te retrouve par exemple la grogne
avait une robe qui l'a choisi c'est tu
la trouves et accusé une capture et
pouvez rechercher exactement la même
robe et tu les as elle me plaît bien
mais pas en rouge tu tapes vert est en
fait tu vois que tu as une recherche
avec plusieurs facteurs en fait c'est
exactement ça c'est nouveau c'est le
multi ça ouais c'est le multisurf qu'en
fait c'est basé sur ce qu'on appelle une
recherche multi modale c'est à dire
qu'on se dit à l'époque il ya une
dizaine d'années quinzaine d'années une
recherche c'était quelques mots qu'on
taper dans le moteur et il y avait une
approche statistique très peu
d'intelligence artificielle là
aujourd'hui on a intérêt beaucoup dia ça
permet d'améliorer le moteur de
recherche est là maintenant avec le
multimodal c'est l'idée de se dire il ya
le texte évidemment mais il ya aussi
l'image est aussi le son est aussi la
vidéo et comment est-ce qu'on peut
rendre tout ça interconnectés et donc en
effet multi search l'idée est de pouvoir
prendre en photo par exemple un produit
une veste on vu dans la présentation
même par exemple à robinet où il
expliquait qu'il était cassé et donc il
a pris en photo le robinet et il a
cherché comment changer l'embout où nous
trouver l'embout et il a vu en effet
comment récupérer cet objet est donc ça
marche aussi en effet avec les vêtements
tu vois un pantalon marron est a envie
d'avoir la même chose en bleu tu peux la
voir et ça c'est hyper intéressant et
donc ça c'est en effet multi search et
ensuite on a développé aussi une autre
fonctionnalité qui va arriver
prochainement en anglais ni remis en
france est à côté de moi du coup qui va
vous permettre par exemple je suis en
train de lire un magazine et là je vois
un plat on va prendre je sais pas moi un
poulet au curry ou une salade grecque
peu importe je vais le prendre en photo
et je vais avoir la possibilité en eau
d'appuyer sur ni remis donc à côté de
moi à cliquer dessus et en fait il va y
avoir une recherche multimodal qui va se
faire une ia qui va s analyser en fait
le contenu de la photo regardez sur le
web qu'il existe et ensuite croiser ces
informations là avec les informations
google maps et donc on va pouvoir avoir
une liste de restaurants autour de là où
je suis actuellement qui te propose ce
que propose cette fameuse salade grecque
dans le menu et donc ça me permet de
pouvoir répondre à une envie très
basique de manger nous agressent à la
direccte et c'est génial parce qu'après
que les avis qui va pouvoir retrouver
sur google csaba est-ce que c'est mon
resto où je veux aller manger ou
peut-être un autre exactement c'est tout
l'intérêt de pouvoir mélanger les
sources et le type en fait
d'informations textuelles vidéos photos
et c'est passionnant autre nouveauté qui
est extrêmement intéressante pour nous
notamment parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
smartphones c'est android android 12
l'année dernière c'était matériel you on
voyait la customisation extrêmement
poussée qui reste toujours d'actualité
qui reste là ça bouge pas mais par
contre en droid 13 apporte d'autres
choses qu'est ce que vient raconter de
nouveau android 13 android 13 toujours
basé évidemment sur matériaux l'idée en
effet de personnaliser un maximum
l'interface donc là on va pouvoir aller
encore un cran plus loin donc par
exemple un exemple qu'on nous a présenté
ce soir si vous êtes bilingue ou
trilingue quadrilingue peu importe vous
allez pouvoir sélectionner certaines
applis par exemple en anglais d'autres
en français et pouvoir avoir plus de
granularité dans l'accès aux contenus un
autre point qui est très important pour
android c'est le rendre le plus efficace
possible au niveau de l'interface par
exemple sur différentes plateformes donc
ça va être le smartphone évidemment les
folles d'apple mais aussi les tablettes
est donc là on a développé une nouvelle
version d'android qui est parfaitement
bien adapté
au format tablette qui va pouvoir par
exemple de split et l'écran de prendre
par exemple une image dans google photo
la glisser dans un texte dans un e-mail
de façon très intuitive en fait donc ça
c'est le deuxième élément comment
adapter l'interface à tout type de
produit est le troisième élément aussi
qui est important c'est l'intérêt au par
habilité et faire ce qu'on appelle nous
chez google le better together le fait
que ça fonctionne de façon très aisée
entre tous ces appareils là donc on va
pouvoir faire du copier coller qui sera
fait depuis un ordinateur qu'on
retrouvera sur son smartphone ou sur un
autre produit et l'idée en effet de
faire en sorte que tout ça s'intègre de
façon la plus simple possible pour
l'utilisateur encore une fois ce qu'on
disait cette idée d' ambiante computing
d'effacer un peu la difficulté d'avoir
plein de formats différents
d'ordinateurs de smartphones etc là on
veut salle d'ordinateur ou ce android et
windows phone windows alors ça peut être
une piste de développement en effet mais
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
bien qu' il ya des versions d'android je
pense qu'ils sont compatibles en effet
avec windows mais par contre l'inter à
bord habilité entre une tablette un
smartphone votre smartphone va être de
façon beaucoup plus être fait de façon
beaucoup plus fluide en fait à travers
le temps qu'on pense intéressant alors
c'est vrai que ça c'est des choses sur
lesquelles on voit que vous travaillez
vous développer parce qu'il ya la
solution ont refait surface il réfléchit
déjà aux en terme de hardware derrière
mais c'est des choses qu'on retrouvait
déjà ailleurs dans d'autres marques ou
effectivement à voir ce que nous sommes
copier coller et c'est intéressant
aujourd'hui que qu'on leur trouve et je
te pose la question de windows parce que
en tant que consommateur final il ya
effectivement droid metatron windows de
l'autre côté et autant c'est la force
c'est vrai que chez apple parce que ces
mêmes systèmes partout et ils font tout
mais ça serait intéressant si est ce que
est ce que l'idée plus tard proches
dénoncent une truc comme ça mais d'avoir
une expérience android sur un ordinateur
ça pourrait avoir une pertinence au delà
du chromebook est ce que ça va mais
parce qu'on a on a on a convoqué le oui
ça fonctionnerait évidemment les
chromebook qui fait partie de cette
galaxie google donc il ya déjà des
choses qui se font par exemple on
retrouve ces sms sur chromebook on peut
y répondre on peut mettre des emoji etc
il ya de copier coller qui est
accessible c'est sûr qu'on boucle donc
il ya en effet une intégration de plus
en plus poussée et en fait nous
l'objectif in fine essaie de rendre ces
outils là le plus agnostique possible
c'est à dire accessible depuis n'importe
quel appareil donc on y travaille en
effet à cet aspect accessibilité il ya
aussi toute une notion de sécurité qui
est vraiment mise en avant est de plus
en plus avec notamment
l'authentification à deux facteurs qui
est maintenant par défaut maintenant un
nouvel utilisateur qui créez un compte
va se voir
proposé par défaut d'activer une
validation deux étapes donc en effet la
sécurité hyper importante et c'est
primordial pour nous et donc en effet on
propose par défaut cette validation en
deux étapes et on propose aussi de le
rendre beaucoup plus d'aisé en fait
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui quand tu va
vouloir tout authentifié sur ton compte
google tu vas voir ton smartphone à côté
tu as juste un bouton appuyer pour
pouvoir s'authentifier donc l'idée c'est
de décès de simplifier en fait tout le
processus plutôt que de recevoir des sms
des codes des choses comme ça on va te
permettre de le faire directement depuis
enfin on te le permet même déjà
aujourd'hui de le faire directement avec
un seul bouton sur ton smartphone
appartement tulasne - est-ce que l'idée
ce n'est pas de se dire je me connecte
avec google et ensuite je vais sur
n'importe quel site co qui se passe et
je suis sécurisé vous faites aussi
gestionnaire de mot passe exactement
s'il ya des sites qui permettent pas de
se connecter j'espère le mot de passe ça
fonctionne et de l'autre côté je
m'identifie quelques se connecter avec
google est en effet ce le fait d'avoir
un outil se connecter avec google permet
en effet de sécuriser son compte d'un
point de vue général donc ça c'est sur
l'aspect sécurité et l'autre point qui
était intéressant et aborder aussi dans
l'aspect respect de la vie privée qui
est aussi un homme va dire la deuxième
jambe c'est de donner aussi le contrôle
en fait aux utilisateurs donc là par
exemple on va rendre disponible une
interface dédiée qui va permettre en
effet de pouvoir avoir le contrôle sur
ses informations personnelles donc par
exemple aurélien je pense que ça te
plairait peut-être de voir ton numéro de
téléphone apparaîtra sur les résultats
arrivé une fois de le faire apparaître
en configurant un truc sur twitter et ça
m'a un peu plus celui de changer de
numéro de téléphone et c'est un peu
pénible mari voilà et là en fait cette
interface vas pouvoir te permettre
d'agir sur est ce que ton numéro de
téléphone apparaissent sur les résultats
de recherche est ce que ton adresse
personnelle par exemple apparaît est ce
que ton email apparaît et tu vas pouvoir
avoir la main sur ces informations là
alors évidemment il faut être très
honnête ça disparaît pas du web parce
que c'est accessible quelque part sur un
site web mais en tout cas ça n'apparaît
plus sur le moteur de recherche et pour
nous cela nous paraît une étape très
importante
en effet pour respecter la vie privée
des utilisateurs non c'est génial écoute
merci beaucoup ça passionnant et puis on
regardera sans le testera la garrigue et
une bêta qui est sorti qui discutent
tout de suite 2 d'android 13e commencé
il ya toutes les fonctionnalités
disponibles dessus on va leur revenir la
plupart mai mais ça va arriver au fur et
à mesure du temps en effet et donc les
pixels 7 seront par exemple avec qu'on a
d'ailleurs montré aussi ce soir seront
avec android 13 évidemment et android
très long pour retrouver comme sur les
autres appareils seront émises à partir
du moment où il sera disponible sur un
smartphone il sera disponible ensuite au
fur et à mesure là il ya un travail qui
est fait de façon étroite avec tous les
autres contre constructeurs aussi pour
qu'il puisse être disponible rapidement
mais on le voit historiquement que les
choses vont de plus en plus vite ça me
semble plus vite wave au plus vite et
c'est donc il ya en effet un travail qui
est fait étroitement avec eux bon écoute
c'est passionnant merci beaucoup merci à
toi c'est très très bientôt voilà vous
savez tout on vous a tout le monde peut
tout expliquer alors c'est un peu
compliqué d'avoir des tous ces points en
quelques minutes comme ça donc on
reparlera je pense de ces questions dans
le podcast ultérieurement parce que
c'est un sujet qui est très complet
youri plein de choses à raconter sur sa
très passionnant alors ya des choses
qu'on ira regarder ensemble on en
reparlera plus tard des solutions qu'on
proposait google ici notamment au niveau
du software vous savez sur un googledocs
par exemple à ce que vous avez un grand
document entier bien vous pouvez avoir
résumé que va bouffer à google grâce à
de la glace artificielle où il a bâti ce
document il parle de ça en gros a besoin
de faire un résumé de texte et bien que
vous soyez scolaire dessus dans le monde
professionnel il le fera pour nous donc
ça c'est cool et il ya plein de
solutions intelligentes comme ça qu'ils
arriveront on en reparlera que ce soit
sur youtube ou même pourquoi pas sur les
autres et reçoit tik tok instagram et
compris donc ça c'est chouette donc
rester connecté abonnez-vous si ce n'est
pas déjà fait puis dit parce que ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez google a eu
ce qu'elle vous intéresse et ce qu'elle
vous avez est-ce que vous utilisez
beaucoup les services google et est ce
que vous conseillez continue et
justement les utiliser après ces
annonces c'est ce que vous allez
utiliser mois peut-être d'ailleurs
directement aux commentaires est ce que
vous avez envie de rentrer dans
l'écosystème global produit qui est en
train de se dessiner du côté de chez
google pixels que ce soit au travers de
votre montre que ce soit au travers de
vos écouteurs avaient déjà mais y en a
deux qui vont arriver les pros que ce
soit au travers d'une tablette au
travers d'un smartphone et de tout ce
qui arrivera à l'avenir parce qu'elle a
plein qui vont arriver dit moi ça en
commentaire tout ça cool on en reparle
et puis on sera encore un tour du
propriétaire des paroles là c'est beau
c'est google c'est bauchi google voilà
on s'amuse donc les bisous ciao
[Musique]